welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 4 the nexus event
in which loki lovin himself may save the
multiverse from robot puppets and loca
gators
let's break down this episode shot by
shot for all the easter eggs and visual
clues that you might have overlooked to
figure out what the hell with 1l is
going on
and a reminder that the best way to
support us here at new rockstars is to
get yourself some great merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com including this
limited edition loki out of time
shirt that i will be wearing in every
video because i love
it so this episode opens on asgard from
sylvie's timeline the opening shot rises
up behind the green hills that enclosed
the kingdom a reversal of the past
thor centric establishing shots of
asgard that approached from the bifrost
gate because for sovie asgard wasn't a
hometown that she returned to after
battle to revel in glory it was a rustic
hearth that she dreamed of those
adventures from she plays with toys
but valkyrie flies over defeats the
dragon and saves
alcohol like thor admitted in ragnarok
sylvie's fan crush was valkyrie
riding her pegasus now the dragon may be
the muspelheim dragon that thor slayed
in ragnarok's opening she also has a
wolf
perhaps fenris hela's wolf steed and
this viking boat actually another of
which can be seen over by the seat in
the background
then the tva comes in and arrests her
for no apparent reason
other than she's a loki but perhaps
since sylvie sees herself in a heroic
light that could be what causes the tva
or the mystery figure actually
controlling the tva to see her as a
potential threat
because that person wants loki's to be
the bad guy and die prematurely now this
squad is led by
rentslayer before she became a judge now
hunter a23
which is probably a reference to
avengers 23 in 1963 the first comic
appearance of ravona rinslayer in which
time traveling villain kang the
conqueror professes his love to her but
she rebuffs him so you know he moves to
destroy your home which fellas is not
the response to no
but the writers choosing ravona
rinslayer as opposed to
any tva judge from the comics feels like
it could be a deliberate move to
introduce kang into the mcu and
referencing the specific comic issue
where ravonna was introduced and that
relationship was front and center
seems like a pretty big hint toward that
perhaps kang is the one pulling the
strings of the tva
he's the one who used his time travel
abilities to create this bureaucracy
that could manipulate time in a very
specific way
and now sees all loki variants who
survive as chaotic nexus beans who
destabilize his perfect timeline i mean
now that the timekeepers are revealed to
be
android puppets controlled by a mystery
man behind the curtain and richard e
grant is playing a different character
that leaves a vacuum for a big bad light
kang to
appear ahead of jonathan major's
portrayal of him in quantomania though
in interviews majors claims to have no
idea what we're talking about so we'll
see
now we never see what happens with the
figurines silvia was playing with they
don't get erased with a reset charge so
maybe they were collected by rentslayer
for her creepy collection of trophies
i mean kang's kingdom of chronopolis
which could be that city in the quantum
realm
is in the comics similarly made up of
architectural relics of trophies from
history's kang has conquered so young
sylvie goes through the booking process
from a lower and much scarier vantage
point she notices the four-all-time
always tva seal that loki walks right
over in the pilot
her transcript stack is much shorter
than loki's since you know she's much
younger and has spoken much less in her
life but notice that guy's mug
does not yet feature his beloved cat and
silvie doesn't like look down to see any
cat in the corner so that cat might have
been a more recent acquisition and by
the way i hope the cat's name is
strodinger because that would be awesome
the girl is scanned to determine she is
not a robot
which since the timekeepers are androids
might actually be to prevent other
robots from entering the tva and
detecting that secret because you know
i'm bot phobic and i ignorantly assume
all robots know each other rentslayer
meets with the timekeepers who are
arranged much like the goofy future
leaders in their floating seats and bill
and ted's excellent adventure to me just
a little clue pointing to these
timekeepers being really the makings of
someone less grand
yet still excellent but behind them is
this red
glowing symbol that looks similar at
least to the runes that agatha and wanda
used to mark a magical boundary to
prevent
others from using magic within that
boundary like perhaps similar sorcery
was used by whoever built the tva to
keep
loki and sylvia and others from using
their magic within this setting
now after the credits we cut once again
to a close-up of the face of the central
time keeper the one whose head by the
end of this episode will be cut off
now mobius wants to talk to c20 but
rentslayer says
dad obvious what
how oh owen wilson may not get to say
wow
in the series but he does get a solid
how
how loki and sylvie sit on the doomed
lamentis one
i'm sorry i remember asgard
yeah i like how that meteor whizzes like
a bullet through sylvie's head at the
moment she cracks to open up to loki
about her past
and sylvia says the tva arrested her
because she's a source of chaos
the universe wants to break free so it
manifests chaos
like me being born the goddess of
mischief and she may be right she did
really nothing to spawn a nexus event
she was just targeted because someone
fears all loki's who don't die
prematurely
we may lose sometimes painfully
but we don't die we survive
now back in the tva the screen shows
wrightville pennsylvania
january 6 1832 that's referring to a
bridge over the susquehanna river in
1832 that collapsed due to ice and
flooding then morag the planet where
peter quill recovered the power stone
and guardians of the galaxy revisited an
end game
which was a planet that used to be
covered by vast oceans until the water
receded
perhaps due to some environmental
catastrophe now above those are mentions
of
sakar that's the trash planet from
ragnarok and alberta canada the province
containing calgary
site of one of the worst catastrophes in
the year 1970 the birth of this piece of
and i am a very very proud
whackover
and later on in the scene when they lock
on to lament one above you can read
unidentified planet interesting since we
know the tva has seen all of historical
existence
and by the end of that there are still
some planets that remain unidentified
and then barcelona spain again and then
a bit later after barcelona there's
aladon referring to
aledon prime a decimated planet that the
cree army retreated to
in the annihilation conquest comics and
then after that lima peru
now we get this gnarly point of view of
the shot from the planet crashing toward
lamentist one as it breaks apart
reminds me of the point of view shots
from the asteroid in armageddon that
movie is crazy but to be honest it gave
us some really fun stuff to look at so
it is loki and silvi's connection that
leads to this
intensely powerful branch the nexus
event of this title it is so powerful
that it defied the apocalypse that
should have prevented this branch from
forming
meaning that these two free surviving
loki's connecting falling for each other
as opposed to killing each other
represents the greatest threat to the
person behind the timekeepers and their
sacred timeline essentially this is like
loki squared to them but they get
captured and moby's throws loki through
this
red door that's outlined in the same
kind of neon glow as the timekeeper's
rune
so perhaps it represents a different
kind of inner tva magic in this case
it's this time
cell a looped memory torture prison kind
of like something you'd see in black
mirror but jamie alexander returns as
lady siff you conniving craven pathetic
worm you did this what
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
now sift did not die with the warriors 3
in ragnarok and she is expected to
return in thor love and thunder
loki cutting sis hair is actually from
norse mythology in which loki cut off
sif's hair and to make up for it went to
nidalee where the dwarves crafted her
new hair from gold
actually led to the dwarves crafting for
the gods all kinds of things like
mjolnir now i love how you can hear the
loop track resetting each time
because it was just a bit of fun
you and while we're talking about the
sound mix of the scene each of sif's
successive hits get louder and louder on
each pass to convey that increasing pain
level on loki
pathetic so mobius tells b15 that they
have brought in cree
titans and vampires cree referring to
the imperialist cree from captain marvel
they also might have shown up in that
miss minutes animation titans could
refer to the people of titan that's
thanos's home world
genealogically thanos is an eternal with
a deviant gene
though maybe once they all relocated to
titan they just went by the name titans
and vampires acknowledges the existence
of marvel vampires soon to be explored
in titles like blade
actually vampires were brought up
previously in thor ragnarok want to use
a big wooden fork
no yeah not really useful unless you're
fighting off three vampires that were
huddled together
silvia's being interrogated in time
theater 47 could be a nod to marvel what
if 47 in which loki takes thor's hammer
i only bring it up because we actually
see a version of loki with a version of
mjolnir in the post-credits scene now in
loki's interrogation room notice the
overhead lights how when they first come
back into it they shift downward
this room might be part of one of the
spires that we've seen in the tva
exterior that rotates past whatever the
outside light sources
the camerawork uses this lighting to
really great effect like when loki tells
mobius that he
and all the tva employees are variants
so before this you had a past
maybe you had a family a life
[Music]
nice try yeah notice how for a moment as
mobis considers this possibility the
light
of truth shines on his shoulders but
then he leans back forward in shadow to
signal him blocking that notion back out
but then as mobius says he and loki's
interest are no longer aligned the
overhead lights
shift back upward in the other direction
and then as loki says that mobius is
lying to himself the light behind mobius
shrinks back down but before i continue
this video is brought to you by our
friends at
manscaped the best in men's below the
waste grooming
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels
they just launched their fourth
generation trimmer the lawnmower 4.0 and
it is a
doozy it's got an led light it's got
wireless
charging and an adjustable guard with
four length settings now as with the
previous lawn mowers the 4.0 has a
ceramic blade with skin safe technology
you know to avoid the bag snags the
pouch ouch
the puncture of your private juncture
they've also got products like the weed
whacker nose hair trimmer
their crop preserver their crop reviver
so if you're still using a face razor to
trim your
non-face hair you might as well be
scrubbing your armpits with your
toothbrush
join over two million men worldwide who
trust manscaped make yourself a little
less
beast and a little more silver surfer
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code loki at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use the code loki unlock your confidence
and always use the right tools for the
job with manscaped meanwhile still
shaking off the memory
that silvi reconstructed when she
possessed her in episode two b15 now
sees this poster that reads did you get
them all
verified through deletion with this big
brothery and mustached man whom we have
seen in the credits now i'm getting some
howard stark vibes from this guy
but i'm thinking it could be some
veteran tva director maybe he who
remains who created the timekeepers in
the comics in rensselaer's office this
music plays
this is licinia the swan by composer
camille sansone
played here though by clara rockmore
really the first maestro of the musical
instrument the theremin
actually loki director kate herron said
she played rockmore's rendition of this
song
in her pitch to direct this series and
that is why you hear the theremin so
often throughout this show
so rinse layer signs loki's execution
order using the same fdr high school pin
that moby has noticed in episode two
note how he looks down at it again
here and rant slayer says cheers
cheers to putting all this behind us
amen yeah mobius might know his path
here will lead to his own pruning so
it's a bit fitting that he uses this
religious affirmation so rinse layer
adds to her trophies sylvie's sword
while moby switches their ten pads and
abruptly leaves
one drink i think i do didn't i
mobius yeah mobius is plain drunk here
but being confused over how many drinks
he's had connects to when he did not
remember leaving ring stains on her
table
just saying he might not be the first or
only mobius out there nor the last
so sylvie reconstructs b15's memory i
looked happy
masaku so good she cries real tears here
but they mix in with the raindrops on
her cheeks
a nod to the famous tears and rain
monologue blade runner which was a major
inspiration for loki also at this moment
cited in one division with that tan
hauser gate sign with b15 facing a
similar realization as replicants that
her memories give her humanity that has
been denied to her so mobius confirms
from rinslayer's temp pad
that she prunes c20 as a cover-up so he
goes to tell loki
you can be whoever whatever you want to
be
even someone good i mean just in case
anyone ever told you different
and loki responds with this heartfelt
grin which sadly leads this moment where
mobius knows ravana is about to prune
him so he says where he would always
want to go
and wherever i had a life before the tva
came along
who had a jet ski that's what i'd like
to do
just riding around on my jet ski prune
him
get this man a jet ski well considering
loki got pruned to this exile place it
is possible doing this could have
unplugged mobius to his past life jet
skiing i mean let's hope so we know from
trailer footage
this isn't the last time we're gonna see
him but also again that scream as they
get erased it's so haunting and notice
how it ends with this digital zip sound
almost like someone being zipped up in a
time body bag
in the elevator silvia asks what was my
nexus event why did you bring me in
i don't remember that little smirk it's
similar to what thanos said to wanda
maximoff an in-game
you took everything from me
i don't even know who you are and what
don draper said ginsburg in the elevator
i feel bad for you i don't think about
you at all
so on to the timekeepers chamber it
looks like it was designed from
mcescher's relativity lithograph
looks very cool and the timekeepers
greet them
[Music]
the are these muppets i especially
love the lorax one or two have to fight
for yourself
but this artificiality is the idea they
are positioned high up
bathed and missed much like the great
and powerful oz just assigned to us that
they're clearly about to be revealed as
a smoke screen
after the fight sylvie decapitates the
central time keeper eliciting laughs
from the other two until they've shut
down like chucky cheese robots
fake mindless androids
i love how its mouth continues to twitch
like ash the android several head and
alien
and with the wiring and the twitchiness
it's just very hollow the president's
animatronics the production design stays
consistent with the tva's 70s analog
tech but yes this confirms that the
timekeepers are not
sacred deities and much of what we heard
in that missed minutes welcome video was
probably a lie rather these were the
artificial creations of someone else
now in the comics that was he who
remains the elder tba agent at the end
of all time but in the comics they
aren't like mindless robots like this
they're really sentient beings with real
power who operate independently but some
believe these robots could be based on
the doom bots of dr
doom or that he who remains could be
some other past loki variant a king loki
or even that this is all automated
clockwork with no one at the helm but
miss minutes but i think based on ravana
being their advocate
a person who got promoted to judge
despite losing a variant in a courtroom
who now seems
okay with loki killing her off as if
someone who's been a prisoner in this
position
i think the chances are looking a bit
better that kang could be behind this
all
and there's no chance i'll regret
theorizing that but right as loki is
about to confess his love to silvi
rinslayer prunes him through the back
just like how he got colson but i also
like how for a second it seems like his
heart is glowing out of his chest
and his face is the last thing to fade
similar to how when vision faded
the last thing wanda saw was his face
now over the credits plays brenda lee's
if you love me
really love me with lyrics about love
eternal even when life is over similar
to how these two loki variants have
survived several apocalypses and
actually one shot in the credits has
been updated to include among the
photographs of loki and silvia
photograph of
sylvie as a young girl then the
post-credits scene where loki awakens
this is
hell now the captions reveal he is
spelling it with one
l meaning he's referring to the
afterlife of norse mythology not the
christian hell and then he hears a voice
not yet but you will be unless you come
with us
so these are credited as classic loki
played by richard e grant
he's dressed up in the bright yellow and
green look from the comics maybe he's a
loki variant that was pruned from the
comic
universe then boastful loki who carries
a version of mjolnir that appears to be
a
truck piston attached to a piece of
train rail
and then kid loki another character from
the comics who carries an
alligator with its own loki crown now
loki in the past has performed conjuring
with animals like snakes and frogs
actually the frog was itself a reference
to the throg
comics but the voice we heard was
richard e grant's though it was off
screen leading some folks online to
speculate that this could have been the
gator talking i don't know about that i
hope it's the case though now they are
in the ruins of new york city you can
see avengers tower back there
and you could see this as the aftermath
of the battle of new york in which
either loki won or maybe where iron man
failed to divert that nuke you can
actually hear the orchestra notes that
are part of alan sivestry's avengers
theme
unless you come with us
[Music]
who but look closely at that particular
avengers tower that is not
the 2012 era stark tower which did not
yet have the upper quinjet landing pad
that was not added until the next time
we saw the tower in 2015's age of ultron
so i am thinking this could be sometime
after 2018
after the sacred timeline loki died
because at that point earth was in the
aftermath of thanos snap and then maybe
the tva prunes all variant loki's that
they capture to this
exile timeline to keep them from
respawning in some other place in time
and this could mean president loki and
the ragtag bunch around him
are all banished loki's who have gone
nutty in this prison
we'll explore this more as we go on to
episode 5 but god damn what an episode
of television we just watched and again
you can support us by checking out our
merch options at newarkstartsmirch.com
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you